the Joe Rogan experience it's good
stressful but it's good well I mean it
has to be stressful you're the king of
the hill yes yes and there's a lot of
things they don't tell you do not bury
up there Matt Hughes when he lost a BJ
Penn I was interviewing him in the
Octagon he said something like really
honest and very shocking
he said honestly he goes into relief he
goes like being the champ and the stress
of it all he goes I'm real relief to
have been lost like first of all to lose
it's very like the fact that he had the
balls to say that like just admit it
like hey it's a relief like you know he
just choked me out but I'm happy I'm
happy that it is for guys like that that
have reached that status it is the
Anderson Silva yeah the George st.
Pierre those guys it is a relief because
you know and I'm just I'm starting to
see a little bit why because as soon as
I walk out of there defending your title
as soon as you just beat this kid up
fans can't wait to say oh no this is the
guy that's gonna be yeah that's the guy
that's gonna beat you so there's there's
really no calm down you know let me take
a vacation me do this
no because fans are on it they want a
guy to step in there with you tomorrow
to beat you that's always gonna happen
yeah you know but everybody anybody
who's a champ yeah but that that's not
imagine doing that five six seven times
over and over and like these guys George
st. Pierre okay's have done over it just
gets overwhelming because it's like
nothing's ever good enough for you guys
you know I can't go out there put on a
flawless performance win and just have
you guys say you know what he's the best
no it's like you were good but yeah this
guy is gonna beat you this guy this is
good enough there's always gonna be a
certain percentage of people that are
not happy with anything I saw people
that are tweet and talking [ __ ] about
Conor after he just won flawless victory
42nd knockout of Donald Cerrone and they
were like that doesn't prove [ __ ] you
know he's gonna fall apart if he fights
anybody good as soon as he gets in there
with a wrestler this and that blah blah
blah it's like some people are just
negative and absolutely you can't fix
them you just gotta accept them the way
they are just like I know and it's one
of the advice to every shot gave me
early on
is uh make friends with this make
friends with uh cuz I you know you get
worked up before a fire you know so he's
like nah make friends with that feeling
because that's a good feeling you know
or you're backstage before your fight
you're super nervous you want to take a
[ __ ] you know you wanna pee you pee like
50 times
you barely drinking water but somehow
there's some kind of pee coming out and
he's like no make friends with that
feeling you know the moment you accept
that feeling it's not that big of a
burden anymore Rashad's a wise man a
super wise me that's a very that's a
very wise piece of advice because you
can really change your perception based
on how you approach something and just
decide oh yeah this alright this is a
part of the process this is what's up
big for me right now yeah very very big
for me because I am a creature of a
routine I love having a routine and and
it's a fine line between routine and
obsessive-compulsive mmm and then it's a
very very fine line yeah because and it
started on for me early on when I when I
started to succeed in wrestling I was i
okay this is my routine okay I'm looking
at the okay I'm 10 matches out so that
means I need to get up and I need to
warm up my warm-up was the same okay I'm
gonna jog back and forth twice before I
skipped back and forth twice before I I
do my lunges back and forth twice before
I do my stance in motion back and forth
twice like it was it was that routine I
had to do it at that time oh no I'm
going to the restroom I need to pee
before I go for this match but I'm gonna
go into the same bathroom I'm going to
the same stall mmm you know I'm gonna
pee and I'm gonna come out and use the
same sink to wash my hand get one or two
paper towels throw it away go back out
like it got to a point where it's like
that's my routine and then I go out
there and I perform and I win them I get
that that's why that's why I'm
performing so it's like OCD it becomes
there's a fine line so I had to realize
that that's a fine line because it's not
necessarily OCD because when you when it
becomes obsessive compulsive is when for
me when it's when you feel like you
can't succeed unless you do those things
right so it's like dang I forgot to do
that well I'm gonna lose I'm gonna lose
no it's I had to
learn how to control it early because
it's how my that's my routine
but even if I I didn't do that I didn't
have enough time to do that because
sometimes you'll have enough time to do
it right think you know something goes
out of whack matches and early but you
don't have enough time to to get your
routine and so it's I had to be able to
adjust my mind okay we still go out
there and perform we still go out
especially in the fight game you know
you go out this quick - quick knockouts
boom boom boom you thinking you've got
30 minutes to warm up it's up like no
you got that coming back you got ten
minutes
it's like oh I got ten minutes I can't
get my whole routine in
[Applause]